Best friends, Jeanine, Bob, and Moyer
and Sarah Harker,
are in their hometown of Indianapolis.
These moms are dedicated
to connecting moms across the city,
and now we are about to connect with them
and their love of Indy.
Watch this.
(upbeat music)
Hi, Drew, I'm Jeanine
I'm Sarah.
We are so excited
to take you around Indianapolis today
to some of our favorite places.
Drew, you're going to love it.
I cannot wait.
Did you just say Drew, as in Drew Barrymore?
Yeah.
Wow, hey Drew!
Hey guys.
Hey Drew, it's Ryan and Jillian
from Indy-Now, on Fox 59.
Yeah, we were just going into work.
What are you guys doing here?
We are going to do a road trip for Drew,
and take her to some of our favorite spots
around Indy, today.
Awesome, awesome!
Yeah, we're on a tight schedule
All right well.
We're rollin behind schedule.
Gotta go, have fun!
All right, Drew, let's go!
We're at Holiday Park,
it's one of the gems of the Indianapolis park system.
I love the programming at Holiday Park,
including yoga at the ruins,
which is where we are today.
It's a little rainy out,
thanks a lot Indianapolis weather,
but I think we'll still get a good class in.
Reach your right arm up,
take a big stretch.
You're gonna love The Garage,
it's one of our favorite places
to grab something to eat.
There's a ton of different vendors
that you can choose from.
And it was just recently voted,
one of Time Magazine's number one places to visit
in the country.
Don't forget, we've got one more place
that we need to take you.
Any ideas?
Give me a hint.
Okay, ready?
Okay.
Let's go to the Speedway.
(Jeanine laughing)
You're gonna love the Indianapolis Motor Speedway,
this is one of the biggest and best attractions
in the entire city.
It is where racing happens all year round,
Indianapolis is a racing capital of the world.
Drew,
we got your flag ready for you on your Camaro.
You're so ready.
Thanks so much for hanging out with us today, Drew,
we've had a blast.
We have loved showing you around Indianapolis,
and I think we need to take one last lap.
Here we go.
Hi Drew, it's Anna Foster,
and I am standing in front of WBZ TV
in my hometown of Boston.
I love Boston because it's rich in culture,
it's rich in community,
and it's rich in innovation.
I want to show you around Boston,
so come with me Drew,
we're gonna have a great time.
(upbeat music)
So we're right here in City Hall Plaza
in the heart of Boston,
and I have a special guest with me.
Drum roll,
the mayor of Boston,
Mayor Kim Janey is right here standing next to me,
I'm so excited.
Mayor Janey, tell us about Boston
and why you love this city?
Anna, thank you so much.
And a shout out to everyone watching.
I love my city,
this is the city that I'm born and raised in,
I am a city girl.
Boston is a great world class city,
a city of innovation,
a city of first.
We are the birthplace of America,
the birthplace of public education,
first library, the best hospitals in the world,
the best universities,
public space, beautiful parks.
And I'm just so grateful and honored
to serve as the first woman mayor,
the first black mayor of Boston.
It is amazing.
Wonderful.
Thank you, Madame Mayor, Kim Janey!
Well Drew, that's a little bit about
my hometown of Boston.
I cannot wait for you to visit,
see you soon!
Hi Drew, my name is Jamie Reibenbach,
and I'm standing here in front of CBS3,
in my hometown of Philadelphia.
I'm so excited to show you around today.
I'm a real estate agent here in Philadelphia,
and one of my favorite things to do
is to show people around
who are coming to Philadelphia
for their very first time.
Let's say hi to Jim and Janelle
from the CBS channel three morning show.
Good morning!
Hi Drew, welcome to Philly.
Yes, the city of brotherly love,
and sisterly affection.
Thanks for joining us.
Welcome to the fabulous Reading Terminal Market
that's over 150 years old.
There's more than 80 vendors.
Everything from buying gifts,
to pretzels, to cookies, to ice cream.
I love coming here, and Drew,
I cannot wait to show you what's inside,
you're gonna love it.
You need to check this place out,
best bagels, best lox,
best cream cheese in the world.
Love this place, Herschel's, east side,
best sandwiches, anything.
Is anybody in the mood for cheese?
Because if you are,
then you've gotta come to the Real Cheese Shop.
You'll find everything that you want.
Here we are, at the art museum,
the iconic art museum, at the end of our tour.
I hope that you enjoyed yourself as much as I did.
I love showing Philly around,
especially to viewers,
and I hope that you enjoyed it as well, Drew.
I'm a huge fan,
dating all the way back to "ET",
gimme a call when you come town.
(upbeat music)